[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week boy I've been waiting
to say this again and I get to be the
first one to say it cuz we alternate and
the lot was cast to me at the round
table of dim lighting why are you
looking at I just want to make sure you
didn't Irving I don't want to make sure
you didn't screw it up and it's a weak
moment at the round table of dim
lighting that's right we are at the
round table of dim lighting we are back
here with our microphones with our table
with each other talking at each other's
faces and appreciating the places yeah
that have meant so much to our
creativity over the years yeah starting
with this table I mean I'm so glad to be
back here in this spot having this
conversation because just like we talked
about with good mythical morning
shooting on split screen man I was gonna
say that's overrated but we never rated
it too highly no it's just got old real
quick it was nice to be back behind the
desk it's nice to be back behind the
table man now yeah the days of well on
Congress or the days that time period of
USB audio where people began to complain
about my breathing I noticed that people
were complaining about my breathing well
hopefully that those days are over for a
while huffing and puffing and Dad noise
we don't know what's gonna happen we
don't know if there's gonna be a second
lockdown we don't know how this whole
thing is gonna unfold but we know that
we are back in the space that we wanted
to be in now we are wearing headphones
and that is because Keiko who would
normally be worrying about all of this
technical stuff is still in Texas so
when he gets back
I will go I at least will go back to my
take the headphones off you're going
can't let it all hang out but for now
this could all go wrong because we
turned all these cameras on our selves
we turned the audio recorder on
ourselves and we are then going to be
responsible for working putting the
cards all they just they made you know
they make it so easy for us
Nick made a video it was like walking
two toddlers through the process he
almost used a baby voice he could have
used a baby voice and I would not have
been offended because I like things to
be made clear to me and linked I'm
confident that we've got it worked out
and like I said appreciating being back
in this space has led to this
conversation that we want to have today
which is the importance of physical
spaces to our creativity it was
something that I'd I think we knew
instinctively or we had these impulses
to like build an environment around us
that that would enhance our ability to
do what we wanted to do but um it took a
lot to really come to grips with like
okay this is a legitimate exercise yeah
so we're gonna take a trip through
memory lane and kind of trace the spaces
through our career but also talk about
some of the challenges that we've
experienced because of how just unusual
the year 2020 has been and what that has
meant for spaces but I did I've been
sitting on a story I've been sitting on
a story for a couple weeks now
all right I've been wanting to tell you
let it loose man so one of the things
that Shepard and I do together is ride
bikes we don't do it so often for me to
say that it's like our thing I know that
you and Lincoln have gotten into
mountain biking together yeah he's not
he's not huge into it every time I ask
him to do it he reluctantly says yes
well not every most of the time yeah I
and Lando has a bike and I'll take them
biking and I mean we all dreamed about
the idea of as a dad just being able to
say hey let's go do fill-in-the-blank
and are the lights in our kids eyes just
turning on and then being so excited to
go spend the day of adventure with dad
well that only happens in the movies and
it probably happens in their memories
they're probably remember
it finally but in the moment it's like
do I have to go when I mentioned riding
a bike the light goes off right what
happened to us link I don't know video
games but I have noticed that Lincoln
you know as we're starting to allow him
to see some friends in very controlled
open-air environments still with masks
in the in the mix and distancing fully
intact he's he's riding his bike to meet
his friends and like he and Locker
hanging out some and you know right
they're like hanging out outside and
doing some explorations in the
neighborhood and I'm like yes finally
they're doing some of the stuff that
like we used to do might get you hurt a
little bit a little bit of innocent
trespassing well well it's not yeah
maybe maybe we don't know what there
might be some fences that lead to some
water I don't great we don't know yeah I
don't know gonna talk about where
they're going talk about it publicly by
any means but um I was encouraged that
like they're out on their bikes meeting
each other right in like it's like stand
by me they're gonna go five legs buddy
well don't spoil it for you know well
that's good I mean you kind of learned
that all right at the top okay so um
also you can't spoil a movie that
several decades old that's lie no I was
just possible it's playing into the link
you should watch it though and that yes
that's one if you didn't think Ferris
Bueller was you know would while you
stand by me is a different level of
movie it is a intense joyous but sad I
mean it's just so beautiful beautiful
movie anyway so I Drive a biking to go
biking with Shepherd in it this is the
first time that we have you just watered
your dog with your so full so we decided
to go out and you know how it is I mean
for some reason when you make a decision
to be like I'm gonna go out and I'm
gonna ride bikes with my son you want it
to be relatively easy it'll be like okay
I'm gonna take his bike down from the
place that it's hanging in the garage
and we're gonna put it on the bike rack
we're gonna drive to the place that
we're gonna bike but no but of course of
course when I pull his bike down I don't
know where he's time I thought I knew
you
do you remember ever having a flat tire
when we were kids no but it's something
about their telephone there's some
California Spurs I don't because I feel
like I rode the same bike tires and
inner tubes never once like my entire
childhood or at least when I got a bike
I kept that bike and those inner tubes
never had it I had to pump up the tires
occasionally and let me tell you Jack
they tell me Jack there were some sand
Spurs back in North Carolina we never
hit him I don't know what it is but yes
okay so had to patch had to patch the
inner to hold because I didn't have a
replacement of course this requires
taking the wheel off and then I got to
put it back on it was the front tire
thankfully a little bit easier and then
I'm like okay and that for I was so I
kind of got mad at that point did you
invite Shepherd to help you patch the
tire because that was the thought of dad
choice I thought about it alright son
you know what we're gonna learn a patch
of tyre together because I don't know
how to do it either as I know and I do
how to do it cuz I've had to do it like
five times since living in California
but he was like I got the bike down I
was like oh man you got a flat tire he
was like okay I'm going upstairs let me
know when you're ready
it was and then I was just like okay I'm
not I don't want to fight him here right
I'm having to fight him to go right by
if you force him to change it he's not
gonna ride so let me this is a key point
I've already a little bit in a bad mood
Oh fix the bike put the bike on the rack
we go to the place that we're gonna ride
and in Shepherds already complaining is
like dad my bike hurts me and my legs
get cramped it's too small and like okay
well first of all it's not that small
and if you can go out and do the things
that I'm asking you to do today I'll get
you a new bike we I've been through all
of this too I mean all of the flat tires
all of the bribery from
new bikes yeah and so I said Shepherd
the thing that we're going to
concentrate on today is you being able
to stand up and pedal because he'll do
it but he doesn't quite get his weight
he's like really using his quads and I'm
trying to get him to understand standing
up while riding your bike is how you get
power it's how you go up hills you know
this is a this is a quintessential
skillset that I'm trying to pass on to
my kids and by the time I was 11 years
old of course I could stand up on a bike
because all we did was ride bikes around
but the only time that we ride bikes as
a families when we ride bikes as a
family you know I'm saying it's like
he's not riding his biker in the
neighborhood for I don't know exactly
know why it's probably cuz we got so
many hills and it would be really
difficult yeah but anyway we get out
there can't stand up and we're in a
relatively flat area but instead of
taking the concrete path or the you know
paved path that we would normally take
about around this big area I was like
let's go down into some of these like
little trails and stuff it's not like a
mountain biking area necessarily it's
more of a walking area but mountain
bikes are allowed and I just noticed
really early on that Shepherd is lagging
behind right and so I'm going out I'll
get ahead of them then I'll go back and
be like alright Shepherd you got to keep
up with me and this is flat there's I
mean there's nothing this isn't hard I
kept saying I was like this is not hard
we haven't gotten to anything hard yet
he was like well I can make it hard if
you want if you want me to make this
difficult like I can do it I wasn't
there yet oh and he was like what is hot
and this is hard and and he like kept
having to stop and then he was stopped
and he would push his bike like on a
flat surface and I was like Shepherd
you're not getting a new bike it's like
I was like you're not listening to me
you're not standing up you're not doing
any of the stuff that I asked you to do
and so I'm not getting a new bike and
then it just had this look of defeat
I felt bad but I was also like I was
texting Jesse tough love tough love I
was texting Jesse and I was like we got
to do something wait we got to send in
to bike school or something because dad
is failing I don't know what to do oh I
know losing control bike schools if you
want me to ride him down for you and
then we get to this long straightaway
and I'm like a bike school share this
probably his one shepherd I'm like
there's this long straightaway Tomic
Shepherd okay there's no excuse for you
not being able to ride on this it's
almost like concrete there's no sand cuz
he was complaining about like the sandy
part sand and then I just I was like I
was thinking like what is the fatherly
thing to do here what is the thing that
he will remember and so I thought about
what happened with you when you got
drunk in high school well and how I like
dropped you off and made you walk and
then I came back to meet you
okay I didn't really formulate this plan
it kind of just came to me in the moment
and then I was like okay I'm going to
leave him on this straightaway I'm just
gonna bike and I'm not gonna look back
and I'm gonna disappear
I'm gonna disappear and I'm gonna and
I'm gonna see if he's gonna react if
he's gonna respond if he's gonna grab
hold of this moment stand up and he let
him bike to on this path so I go it's a
it's a long way okay I go a long way
just so you do know what you seem like
to everyone listening at this point
right listen
a tyrant no I'm no I'm not tyrant I know
there's an opportunity for growth I know
the feet I know the feeling I'm with you
but no everybody's known I was giving
him an opportunity to respond right for
you think I'm a tyrant
let me tell you some of the stories
about what my high tech my I told you
that I learn how to swim in the river
when my dad threw me into the rear that
makes a all okay okay but no I'm like if
my dad's a 10 I'm a 1 when it comes to
that's not true but ok so I you're
ditching it I Drive off a ride off do
you drive up I in a car this whole time
you left that I think you're right I
mean but I'm commanding the bike I'm not
just riding on it I am driving it and I
don't in the proper term I disappear
over the horizon and then I kind of
stopped under a tree and wait and then I
go back around this little bend and I
look and he is pushing that bike and I
am just not happy about livid but at
this point I was like I just can't you
know I what I got can't do anything I
can't I can't break his spirit anymore
you could go back
the car and leave him there permanently
if you want to abandon your son so I go
to him and I say Shepherd I don't know
what happened today but we got to get
back to the car
and so we start pushing the bikes Oh God
and I'm still thinking about like
fatherly things to say and like how do i
how do i how do i send a message here
how do i give him an opportunity to want
to i'm thinking about preserving his his
desire to bicycle you know i'm saying
like we're in that state at this point
and so I'm like you know what he's going
very slow I'm like let me push your bike
I'll push both of our bikes and all you
have to do is walk okay so I put my bike
in one hand I grab his bike in the other
hand and I begin to walk with it and two
seconds into walking with his bike I'm
like something is wrong with his bike is
it is--there tire it man he's at the
tire and it's my fault you you patched
no no when I patched I patched the front
tire you despised put it on I pumped it
up and I you know you spin the wheel to
make sure that the brake is not catching
right but something happened between
putting the bike on the rack and then
giving him the bike that his front brake
was catching and so the reason he
couldn't do anything
is because it was almost like he was
going up a hill the whole time
regardless of the slope because he was
had he had this resistance in the front
brake and I was like Shepherd you bicaz
messed up man your front brake is
catching that is why you've had such a
hard time today yeah and I was like man
I am so sorry for everything that I just
said to you I thought that you should
have found it I who should have noticed
no I said I thought that you had just
completely given up and I was like he's
been playing too many video games
he's lost his ability to be outside I've
created a monster and then he's laughing
now we're laughing at each other okay
and I'm like Shepherd this is just a
sign that we need to ride bikes more
because you couldn't perceive that
something was wrong with your bike and
as soon as I touched it I knew that
there was something wrong
we gotta ride bikes more I said you know
what when we get home I'm gonna pick you
out a new bike so we went home but we're
gonna break it and you have to figure
out what's brillo my story's not done oh
dang am i i buy on your store I buy a
new bike and because you offered the old
bike you read text me and he's like hey
does does Lando need a bike I'm getting
shepherdess a bigger one cuz he's too
small for this one maybe Lando and you
sent me a picture of it you didn't tell
me that it was bunk it's not no no it's
my fault
it just needs the brakes the front
brakes need to be adjusted it's a good
bike it's a trek I don't want that bike
so I do have a bike available for
anybody who wants it um so we get a new
bike and you know you had bought your
bike at the local bike shop which is
what I wanted support local business but
I decided not to do that because I
didn't want to I'm trying not to go in
places like I'm still not even going
into grocery stores call me crazy but
we're still what I wouldn't call you
crazy I would just call you a bad dad
and a bad shopper right we're trying to
maintain what because we're coming into
the office and we're you know working
with each other and then working with a
very small group of people
everyone who's doing that we're just
trying to maintain essentially an
isolation until we come and work
together so everybody knows hey we're
safe so I'm not really going into any
place yeah and well so I ordered the
bike online and I don't I've never
bought a bike online I thought this
means you know somebody some dudes gonna
ride up on your body yeah I thought you
PS man just rode up put a kickstand down
and gave it to you there is no kickstand
didn't get that kind of bike that's not
what happens a box shows up and it's
called a box build which is most of the
bike has been put together but some very
key elements like the front fork is not
attached to the frame like this is a and
that's that kind of a key part part of
the whole process right oh man and I
called the local bike shop and I was
like I just got this bike in a box he
was like yeah it's called a box build
hundred dollars and we're a month out oh
gosh apparently everyone's doing this
and you could see could sense kind of
bitterness and his voice cuz he's like
you jackass you went and bought it
online you could have just bought it
from us and you know what probably isn't
even a month
wait I called another bike shop they
were like we're a month out it's like
it's the thing today
punitive tell them it's a month out do
you think about returning it and just
getting one from the local no I said
well I'm gonna build it oh I have
YouTube I actually make a living on it I
brought up a YouTube video and at this
point you had a dad choice to include
Shepard in the building of his bike I
knew that I did not need Shepard to
witness what was going to happen knowing
how it's gonna be us could go wrong yeah
seven minutes and I break it I'm trying
to attach the thing to the thing and I'm
you know I'm tightening it down and then
there's like a little cap that goes on
top of your dilly-dally and it like
broke can I ask you you ask me anything
you want when this happens
are you an audible cursor or are you a
mumbler are you a silent cursor I think
all of the above so you do go to audible
cursing range oh yes and is it like
full-on like no it's not are you going
like f bombs well yeah but I'm not but
it's it but it's more of just like I
don't do that I'll be like and I'm I'm
very critical of myself when I make a
mistake like I've done that and I'm like
you effing idiot
i-i'll say things like that to myself
yeah yeah cuz I'm just laying yeah you
should have done this box built in the
first place and not you've screwed it up
I hate that feeling
since when it's a car which I know we've
both also done well early days of
marriage we thought we would have you
know impress our wives by fixing our own
car yes I told her the car one time
engineering good degrees do not help
with practical things like building
bikes and let me tell you the YouTube
videos were not helpful at all at least
the ones that I watched so newsflash I
had to take the bike to the bike shop oh
man talk about the walk of shame and and
of course first of all I haven't been in
a public place so I like I like there's
a the bike shop that we go to there's
like there's an open door then there's
the counter and so I like kind of I kind
of go in I look in there and there's
like three people in the bike shop
everybody's got on masks
they're all standing really far apart
and I gotta just stand in the doorway
until the guy helps the people then he
comes to me and he's like I'm like I box
build I screwed it up I need you to do
it he's like you know it'll be a month
out yes I know it'll be a month it did
say how much hundred bucks I know yeah
and then I said does anyone I could pay
extra to get it faster he's like we've
done that a couple of times and you know
I can't make any promises and also you
end up doubling your investment and what
you paid for this day yeah you
definitely yeah
he was just trying he was pushing me off
of it and I was like okay just let me
know when you're done I'll shamefully
walk back in here and get a bike for my
son and then you know go bond with him
meanwhile as he been watching youtube
videos on how to stand up and bike it's
not how it works you got to just do it
well you still got the old bike yeah I
do i but I have to but I have to fix
that I mean it wouldn't be that hard to
do but I just I'm so mad at that bike
are you mad at the bike or you mad at
someone else it's one of those things
that when you're in the midst of
quarantine and I think that everyone
like the thing that we've been noticing
is the family has just never been around
each other this oh my gosh I know it and
you're just like usually there would be
like somebody would go somewhere like a
kid would go someplace I mean going
school or anything I've just learned
that going places and interacting and
doing other things really even if you're
an introvert there's got to be a certain
level of like at least getting away from
the from the people in your home that
then it's it's nice to realize there's
more world than just the people in your
own home I mean the thing that resonates
with me is the first week of quarantine
I'm like getting water and ice out of
the freaking fridge and there's no ice
and the whole my ice makers broken
I haven't had ice this whole - the whole
time because I didn't want to call
someone to come in the house and fix
it's like the seventeen hundred's fridge
or else we're pouring ice into the
little things and then not refilling it
believing it in there so that when
someone goes for ice and it's just an
empty tray with no water or ice in it
everybody gets
upset and then you know all this winds
coming through and I could you know I
look outside yesterday in the tree in
front of my house like the little tree
that's staked down I mean it's like a
7-foot tall tree but still pretty thin
it's like blowing over because the stake
that was holding it up broke and Here I
am
I mean I'm I can't I'm trying to like
Reese take the tree and I can't even do
it like we're not men anymore man we
can't do stuff that we thought you know
you're supposed to be oh the tree fell
over or the you know the bikes in a box
that's fine or well my phone is a
disappointment I can fix this
I did do plumbing I did plumbing well I
mean the garbage disposal had become
loose and was leaking and tightened
something well no I fell off completely
oh wow and I did I now watched a youtube
video for that and I and I got to a
place where I was about to tell Jessie
we have to call a plumber and but I did
it I did it I was so proud of myself if
there's something it's just hard it's
hard to actually get stuff done and not
screw it up I mean and I kids included
everybody's fuse is a little bit shorter
and it's it's gonna take some kind of
like I know we're both thinking about
doing some kind of vacation like a local
somewhere it's somewhere in California
maybe taking a vacation at some point
well boy it might be five separate
vacations I think we need that
I'm karma calling a firework vacation
where it's like okay go and then
everybody just goes in a different
direction call that the firework yeah
how do you take a vacation and then just
we kind of figured that your kids
somewhere I think all of this again
really brings me back to appreciating
the spaces that we haven't been able to
enjoy like being back here and you know
the our offices and stuff like that
which is what we want to talk about so
we'll get to it but first we're going to
give you an opportunity to just spy the
shirt that link is wearing you might
remember that there was a there was a
time
there was a time on this particular
podcast where we would answer your
questions and then we would leave you
with a little catchphrase good luck with
that and we kind of thought that it was
gonna become the thing that we said in
fact we got a mug that had it on it we
got to start saying it again because
it's on this tea and then we developed
this this the R and leur version of the
R and ler and ethical logo and now we
know that for a tie-dye thing as you
know everybody loves the tie-dye so now
if you want to get the tie-dye good luck
with that t-shirt featuring the R and
ler you need to go to mythical calm to
make that a reality
if you like it Jade take it from Jade
she's looking at go back down she's like
I've never seen things from this view
mythical calm okay
where we still going is a pregnant very
pregnant pause yeah I had to push it out
you actually thought of talking about
space why did you do that what made you
think about spaces well Ian Lincoln
building the thing um well no it was the
fact that we were coming back where it
was - it was twofold yeah what we talked
about but what's the other what's the
other fold it was that yesterday
what's that yesterday yeah we were over
in the creative house and the creative
house you know what the vision for the
creative house of being decorated and
moved in of course the virus also
infected that process has really slowed
it down but furniture for different
parts of the house including the living
room and then some stuff in your office
came in and Lincoln Lincoln we're
putting some of it together
and so I was just thinking about you
know we it's funny because we designed
this space here for ourselves I mean we
didn't design this space that we're in
right now necessarily we took advantage
of the fact that it was like an awesome
recording studio that happened to be
here at this space we were renting but
we designed our space for our office
and then we we've talked about this
already but how we came to the
conclusion that we needed our own space
again ironically because this space
doesn't necessarily say hey rhett and
Link create it's Ezra hey rhett and Link
have meetings be your business boys
supervise and be business business boys
and yes so giving this other space where
it was a new zone where we could express
ourselves and we we knew that that first
meant like setting it up because we have
we have a long history of setting up
spaces like I mean I'll go all the way
back to to college we really started to
appreciate having our own space I mean
that remember how exciting it was when
we moved in to our dorm room at NC State
and I remember the first few weeks of
school you're like walking around the
quad and like you're going to classes
and do you remember this all of these
vendors had set up they were selling
crap mostly posters you remember this
they were selling posters all over like
all over the quad and they were like
huge posters little posters mostly just
like band posters and cool movie poster
and they knew that college students who
were just moving into their dorm rooms
would just go bananas
oh yeah it's a Lulu posters Bob Marley
so many Bob Marley posters I kind of
felt like I needed to get a Bob Marley
poster just because it seemed like the
thing to do but instead we got we got a
pulp fiction poster where Vince Vega and
Jules Jules were I think it's when after
after they were shot at and it
miraculously didn't get hit and they
just opened fire the scene with bread
and then we also bought a meeting a
poster of a meeting between Elvis who
seemed to be like in his like lot last
days only the last legs meeting
President Nixon and I actually don't
know
the story well Hein that the story
behind the holster poster I was like
okay it's kind of cool
no it was a I'm gonna get some of these
details wrong but my understanding is
that L it was an anti-drug meeting
that's what makes it so funny right yes
Anna it was an ironic post and I think
that they may have even made Elvis like
an honorary DEA officer or something
like I don't know how the legend goes
but they have been talking about drugs
and of course Elvis obviously have been
using a lot of drugs like and you've got
like Nixon in a suit and Elvis in his
suit which is a very different kind of
suit yeah we loved that poster man yeah
and I didn't even know the full story
behind it and I just thought it was like
odd and ironic I could sense the irony I
didn't have to be a didn't have to be
explained to me that's where we got mr.
fly from the from the thrift store like
the the velour couch that then we would
pose like Lionel and made project Lionel
and then we decorated the wall with
pictures of Lionel I mean if you don't
know the story you can get it in the
book of mythicality but you know it was
just so exciting to have this space this
hideout this little dungeon space I mean
we had no light coming in our window was
right under the steps to the first floor
and it was pitch dark in the broad
daylight which is good good for college
because you can just sleep in there in
the middle of day and it feels like
night and it smelled like a basement I
like it was very dank in that sense and
then we moved to an apartment with Greg
and then the next then the next year is
when Tim moved in too but the apartment
was like whoa it's not just one room now
like we don't just have to have this
little fridge I think it was Lily that
asked me other day she's like what did
you have in your dorm room to cook with
I was like toaster oven a microwave you
know we had a we had a fridge dorm
fridge with a toaster with a microwave
sitting on top of it and then a toaster
oven sitting on top of that the triple
threat yeah that's awesome maybe that is
one unit that they sell for coffee
that's a good idea it's probably a huge
fire hazard
and also like itll fridge microwave too
much amps poster oven I I'd love to have
a fridge that you could just put bread
into the side of it and it pop out toast
that's pretty cool or it's a toaster for
now what it is good idea it's a fridge
that's got a toaster in a microwave and
when you place your hand on one of the
objects in the fridge it knows whether
to send it to the toaster oven or the
microwave and then on top of that it's
got like a humidifier or like one of
those what's those vaporizer things that
like our wives put around our house and
I I'm addicted to it yeah a vaporizer
that makes smella
smells nice smells that seems
unnecessary that feels like maybe that
isn't a deluxe package deluxe package
man yeah you got it you gotta sell them
up we're gonna put that on mythical calm
take notes
yeah but we always thought and this is
we weren't seeing it as a creative space
at the time we were seeing it as a space
to to live in and express ourselves and
but we ran coax cable to connect
multiple televisions in multiple rooms
so that we could have people over and
watch movies in multiple rooms at once
well and we had the Planet of the Apes
party if I recall correctly and yeah I
don't know if we've ever told this story
I'm sure we have but we got this idea
that we were going to invite every woman
every woman that we saw on campus this
is a sound like a you and Greg guy it
was definitely a me and Greg I mean I
was dating Christie so I was I had to
like yeah I had to wash my hands of this
plot so Greg and I were like alright
what we're gonna do is interested when
you see a group of women on campus you
just walk up to them and you say hey
we're having a Planet of the Apes party
3000 to see gorman crossings Friday
night 7:00 p.m. whatever we said bring
whoever you want yeah now keep in mind
and they're like Planet of the Apes
party so yeah we're gonna watch plane
today
don't matter what room of the house
you're in you'll be watching it in sync
with everyone every TV would be playing
planet eggs now
let me just say a couple of things we're
not we're talking about the original
Planet of the Apes right cuz the new
ones hadn't come out yet Charlton Heston
and we weren't because we were you know
we were involved in the Campus Crusade
campus ministry as we have talked about
extensively we weren't drinking so there
was gonna be no alcohol but not only was
there going to be no alcohol there was
going to be no anything like no drew and
actually this was part of the experiment
do you remember this I showed up late no
no I didn't have it I didn't help plan
out it me and Greg it's almost like
attended me and Greg they helped Planet
of the Apes thought that it would be
like a social experiment but provide
food or drink oh no drink just planet
[Music]
[Laughter]
and the worst party I mean you if you
take care of the big things at a party
the little things take care of
themselves yeah like if you got a bunch
of strangers I was gonna say a bunch of
strange women but I just women that you
don't know you only invited women and
then they can invite anybody they
because if you invite women men will
show up I mean they'll come out of the
woodwork well because we knew that our
like dude friends are gonna show up but
yeah and first of all I don't believe
that any of the women that we didn't
know who we just randomly asked on
campus can't believe any of them came
but I think they saw through their wow
this is a typical plan of the AIDS party
no food no drink no you know no fun they
probably won't let us even use the
restroom I don't know no I don't mean
for it if you're not drinking so but it
was so there's a lot of people there
though you knew that it was kooky it was
just it means that a fair word to say it
was just like so it was intentionally
odd yeah and so it gave you the
confidence if I'm if I'm to go up to
strange women on campus you know because
it was just like this is weird so me
going up to someone I don't know is less
weird than what I'm gonna say once I get
up there
so it was like true you had to work up
once you worked out the gumption to have
the party inviting strangers was easy
it's kind of brilliant kind of brewing
I'm glad you think that but then I never
thought of execution you had the whole
thing was a ploy to work yourself
up to talk to strange women but if it
hadn't been a good party and like
memorable it would have happened again
there was there's more Planet of the
Apes movies yeah well that was the idea
the show the first one see what happens
I don't recall it ever happening
disaster
you're not we're not really talking
about the space beyond the coax cables
like going from room to room and not
well hidden but we but also at that time
the our idea of what a space was going
to be was so like college it didn't
matter dudes a washer and dryer were in
the kitchen kitchen yeah I was doing the
laundry and when I saw that giant ass
rat come out from underneath the
refrigerator yeah yeah so I mean it very
scary but but our first work space was
not really that great of a space because
you know when after engineering there
was the stent working with Campus
Crusade at the regional office we were
working in cubicles we went into like a
meeting room and we would set up a
camera and we would whisper into a
microphone and those are our first
videos but it wasn't our own space it
wasn't and you know and so we wanted our
own space it was around this time that
with Campus Crusade since we were we had
special roles as like we would travel
and we would speak and we were like
resident videographers and like all the
things we talked about like emcees and
sketch artists comedian guys sketch
artists they there was a conference that
they put on just for the creative types
within Campus Crusade and we were and
this was a national conference but in
where they pulled together everybody
from all the regions andrea tivities on
it called the creativity summit because
when you're in a like a campus ministry
and or maybe maybe this is true of any
kind of group but they like to put on
conferences oh yeah and we got it was an
invitation only we most of the people
who worked in the organization they
worked on campus you know they didn't
they did they weren't the creative type
like a graphic designer or you know
a filmmaker videographer type like we
were so we were invited to this thing it
was in conjunction with the Film
Festival out here in los angeles de ma
this was our first trip to los angeles
super exciting I mean we started meeting
other creative types from other regions
it was very cool it was very inspiring
and then they had speakers to talk about
cultivating and legitimizing creativity
because our roles and everyone who was
there their roles were kind of on the
fringe of what the main type of job
descriptions were with the organization
right but I remember one guy talking and
he might have been a former like Disney
Imagineer he was and he's in that
documentary Imagineering oh really
yeah because he was at Disney forever I
remember specifically they talked about
something that seemed so obvious and
it's exactly what we're talking about
now is the importance of space to in to
foster creativity and like I said even
though we had this instinct of like I
made hideouts as a kid and like you know
my ex stepdad Jimmy we built that tree
house and we were you and I would hang
out back there it's like having your own
space where it's like I can cook things
up and I can do my own thing that was
you know that was part of who we were
back from that knowing that the cramped
little office that we were that we were
you know secluding ourselves and was not
adequate for the creative ideas that we
had for specific and it gave us
permission that that guy gave us
permission to want to have a space that
would was conducive for creativity well
in the be hags because he he's like
those are the big hairy audacious goals
Souls also scott derrickson was at that
film festival and like spoke that's
right
filmmakers yeah he he directed Doctor
Strange he directed a lot of horror
movies um so yeah so we get back and
that's when we we know we need a space
and I knew that my father-in-law had
this you know the basement underneath
his what at the time was sort of his
like business head
for the for his dentistry and we saw
this in the LSAT video when we went back
to North Carolina and you weren't able
to go but I kind of it was open so I
went in there but that was the beginning
of us having a space that was
intentionally a creative space and
that's where so many of the sort of the
aesthetics of early rhett and Link stuff
you know see a lot of this has a lot of
this has you know remained to this day
the checkered floor which incidentally
somebody said on YouTube that was like a
little man honey thing so I'll give me a
break no no no I mean I like playing
into it so yes an Illuminati thing
that's why we have the checkered floor
give me a break the original green the
original green rhett and Link good mean
what we I think we picked was really for
Green's we painted a wall green screen
and then we painted the other wall blue
just so we could have a different
background all because you can do blue
screen you can do green screen it
depends on what color you're wearing and
that's when I started collecting those
Merle Haggard albums and we like put
them we put them around the front office
room and since then every where we've
had an office we've moved my collection
of Merle albums they're in the office
right there now but well and there was
it's funny because there were basically
all the elements that we've now always
tried to recreate were technically if
you think about it we're in that space
right you've got a workspace where me
and you have desks together
yep and can kind of develop the ideas
we've got a place where we shoot the
things that we're doing we've got a
studio space which it wasn't it was that
was the back another room back room with
no windows and we had a recording booth
right and because music was such a big
part of everything that we were doing at
that time so we like turned an old
closet into a recording booth it was
just nice to be able to go there and you
know if anybody else stepped in it's
like immediately this is weird like what
in the middle of Harnett County like
people would step in you know some
people would show up
knock on the on the door because it was
like a records office like cattle and it
was government record was right next to
the DWI Center right so if someone who
had gotten a DWI had to then you know
the county made them report to this
place where they would get help and many
of them thought that we were the DWI
center we didn't treat anyone we would
you know that would be irresponsible we
would just send this in then next door
next to her yeah but whenever we stepped
in I remember this feeling of we can do
whatever we want you know it was just
like this exciting level of freedom well
there's a pressure that comes to I think
in an expectation that all right we set
this up how you said the space so if we
can't start making stuff if we don't
make stuff it's it's it's our own fault
and we we made stuff oh yeah and I think
that that like that getting the space
that we needed that was one of the most
I mean not in not in terms of the amount
of content because now we create more
content than we ever did and it's sort
of steadily increased but that was sort
of the beginning of us being very
prolific in terms of the amount of stuff
we were working on and creating no one
that we saw on YouTube had a space and
everything we shot you know if you watch
our videos you would get to know
everything in his space cuz we shot
everything there or on the street
outside of it just look at the Facebook
song music video you'll see that like
the street corners of Lillington North
Carolina but on YouTube it was you know
it was younger people in their bedrooms
shooting vlogs shooting stuff like that
you know it was you know one was doing
it knowing that I knew I was it was set
up in that way and I I mean I couldn't
imagine that I mean I've kids at home
you know if I was gonna act like a fool
I couldn't do it at home because there's
babies crying well you know I do think
that's a - we can jump we can jump
forward and then jump back but to
contrast that you know there's been a
there's been a few times in our lives
where we've had to involuntarily step
back into a restricted space right and I
and I think that the two times that I
think about most
well I guess three times moving to
California like right because there was
the studio space in Fuquay that was
after the one in Lillington which was
another big space that was even bigger
but then it had to see like highly high
ceilings yes and no toilet sit above us
but we moved to California we were
working with who became our good friends
joke and Biagio joke productions who
produce commercial kings and then we
talked them into letting us have a
little office in their production studio
because we did we were just living in
these furnished apartments and had
nowhere to work but that was a that was
a again a constriction all the space I
like individual edit bays in a high-rise
that's exactly what it was yeah so we
were like in this basically windowless
room with a couple of deaths that like
okay you come in and you work on this
show for a few weeks or months and then
you're gone and someone else at work
here next time you know it was it wasn't
a lot of character but you know that run
over and we were under a lot of pressure
but the thing I remember the most
significant thing that we created at
that time and again it's just it's
pretty obvious looking back to this
constriction of the space sort of like
pressurized just the location was small
and we came up with the what did when we
caption fail caption fail of it yes like
the caption fail series which was a
little bit of uh they were filmed around
there yeah a little resurgence for us on
YouTube because we were able to get a
couple out kind of quickly right but I
think that there's no doubt in my mind
that that came from being in this place
like we can't make a music video really
right now and the only music video in
May was we made the Harry Potter song
which I'm sure I'm super proud of that
song because I remember that we we
worked all night on it it was one of the
few times that like we worked all night
on something in order to turn it around
because we needed like the reason why we
made that song is cuz the the last Harry
Potter movie was coming out and we were
trying to jump on that bandwagon and get
the view
from it in order to then to attach an ad
for commercial Kings so we could get
more people to watch our TV show and it
I mean the it got a lot of views and it
was it was shot right there in basically
the the room where we were working the
ideas fit the setting but when we showed
up at that place it was like this is not
I mean wasn't our space it wasn't our
space and it really there was like a
desperation of what we were we were just
trying to to find our way again
especially once the show got canned well
and then when we not real name we
decided we decided to and this is I've
never really I've never really tracked
the content to the space but you know we
got our own space again I'm you own
space using that pretty loosely because
it wasn't anything compared to what we
had in North Carolina when we decided
that they you know converted garage or
the guest house in my backyard would be
our new studio and that's where good
mythical morning was born and in a
really small I mean I don't know what
that room was and maybe it was you know
like it was this guy's car garage
basically and it's the two of us and
Jason in there working on top of each
other and then there was a time there
was a there was a cuff you months
because it was like also a guest house
like when people came to stay with us
they would stay in there like were the
relatives and then Antonio Antonio when
he first moved out stayed in there for
like a couple of months did he he slept
on our couch that couch yes if the couch
would lay down and like a futon but we
said like hey we got a you got to be out
of here before we get to work every
morning because there's not enough room
physically for the futon and you and all
of us to be here right yeah so it was
there was a bathroom of the shower so
that's why he was able to stay there
everything but we also had but we also
had the yard too you know and that's
where like dope zebra happened and right
in that backyard several other things
that we shot have a graduation song
because we've been you know it's like
there's a there's a really good book
by the Duplass brothers I can't remember
what it is I think we may have redirect
it but basically they kind of talk about
their story and their creative process
and there's a lot of parallels between
the way that they kind of work with each
other that in the way that we've we've
worked together but they talk about the
way that they approach independent
filmmaking and it was to find the space
for the film to find the location to be
like okay we can go to this town this
town has a sheriff's office and a
gymnasium and a library all right
let's write a screenplay where these
locations are featured yeah so they let
the space dictate the screenplay and
that's where a lot of they're like an
issue and that's why it was cheap and
that's why they were able to make a lot
of money off of those or to kind of get
going because they could actually make
it and that's sort of an extreme example
but I think that at each point this sort
of the constriction of the space or the
you know the openness of the space has
then contributed to what we were working
on what we were doing well when you talk
about openness it makes me want to skip
ahead to this studio space here which I
mean when you look at both sides of the
studio and we got like well not all 80
people are working in here and of course
nobody's working in here now and who not
but we got this like open space where
most everybody's working and then
there's enclaves and offices where
people can go in to meet and have more
private conversations and we have our
our office back here in the back but
even this conversations is helping me
really understand what we already knew
instinctively it's like to really get
creative we needed to step out of this
space because it it wasn't doing for us
what what all the previous spaces did
and what this space did at first
mmm-hmm yeah maybe it actually didn't I
mean well I think that again this isn't
necessarily directly creative but
what this space allowed and then what
this what the next-door space allowed is
again I feel like the decisions about
the space have driven the specific
decisions about what we do right so we
got this space we told the story on the
the del sponsored podcast we kind of
told the history of the business and we
told the story of been saying I know
that this place is beyond our budget but
I don't want I want to let you know that
I think that we can take advantage of it
I think that this is the right place I
think we can use it and we took a chance
and we moved in here not having any idea
how we would fill it with a team but
again you naturally fill the space and
so yes we did some good creative work
we've done a lot of good creative work
in this space but I think that what this
has represented more than anything is
the team building in the business
building and then specifically with this
with the the other space is what made
the acquisition of Smosh makes sense
again it was like yes we took the other
space because if we could the other half
of the building you mean yeah yeah the
other half of the building because of
GMM 22 the season that we did the 22
minute version of GMM we needed more
space for more people that only lasted
one season but then it was like oh we've
got this space and then I think that we
were like okay we've done this business
building this team-building thing but
now we kind of got to get back to what
it is that we're gonna personally create
right not just the role like we've
created these products like good
mythical morning or ear biscuits and we
know what our role is and we come and we
sit down and we fill fulfill that role
but what what is the new thing that
we're creating right and I think we we
had a sense that it was going to be easy
for easier for us if we created a new
space that was a trigger for those new
ideas and now we found ourselves
decorating our own offices for the first
time once we get some furniture in there
which is happening do you have any what
what do you have any idea what you're
putting in there I put a big shelf up
because I'm like I think I want to put
stuff on a shelf I think I'm going to
find
stuff that means something to me and
I'ma put it on this [ __ ] yeah Jesse's
getting some some shelves for some stuff
you know and like the RET like setting
up the records and you know I I'm a
shout out to my Instagram
for a while back I put the you got to
say shout out to link Neal and I shout
out to link Neal on Instagram you gotta
actually give the look at my record
shelf that's in the main living room
there I'll be happy makes me happy yeah
well and I'm you know it's been weird
because this has been such a this has
been another really constricted time
right so we weren't really go I mean
I've been going to the creative house
more than you but it's literally going
over to an empty house I mean anything
that you saw me shoot over there you see
me I'm in a chair in front of a blank
wall and I'm also I value the creative
space a lot but I have a very difficult
time getting motivated to actually do
the things to have like I don't like
okay put the shelf together put this cat
like I that I don't like doing that I
like it when it's done but I don't like
doing it right but I very much look
forward to what its gonna be I mean you
know we'll talk more about this in the
coming weeks but you know one of the one
of the ways that we're sort of
exercising our newfound creativity is
where we're doing original stuff on
tick-tock right like that's one of the
things that we're doing we're writing
these sketches and kind of getting back
to this is this interesting thing that's
happened in on tik-tok which is you know
it's not a platform that has a partner
program right now it has this early days
of YouTube feel to it where it just
feels like people who see an opportunity
on this platform and are figuring out
how to build an audience and are trying
creative things are doing it and we've
always approached new platforms as but
for the past few years we've approached
it more as a business or as a brand like
what is mythical going to do on this
platform usually as an extension of what
we're doing on YouTube
for the first time ever and really this
is a very fresh thing for us I mean we
just got a couple of things that we've
liked written and put up there we're
saying like what are we gonna do like
what are rhett and Link going to create
over there and it's a totally different
it's a different exercise but we but you
know but we're just beginning to be able
to like be in the house together it
sounds like it's gonna be decorating
videos shelf building videos bike
breaking videos yeah well I'm sure we'll
talk more about that but yeah I mean
it's rounding out that space and what we
want it to be is makes it makes it a
playground for us to then makes this
make stuff that we want to make and so
it is it is a hurdle that work that
we're starting to clear and I'm excited
about it I'm interested for this space
you know as employees start to come back
to work whenever that starts to happen
it starts working together it's like
what what what's gonna happen to open
floor plans you know are we gonna refer
everybody's talking about how open floor
plans are gonna go away but I mean you
know the coronavirus isn't gonna be with
us I mean it may be with us forever but
it's not going to be the threat that it
is even if it even if it comes if it
doesn't go away it's not gonna be the
threat that it is right now forever I
don't know I I think everyone's saying
well we're gonna reevaluate the open the
open work space because you know what by
the way people don't get any work done
in open workspaces like that's that's
one of the things that I've seen people
writing is they're like people are
distracted and it isn't like everyone's
working together it's everyone's working
and they're together and I mean I don't
know what the answer to that is I mean
we've designed this space so that it's
like okay and it was kind of as simple
as which employees might need to have
sensitive conversations and or be on the
phone yeah but it's those people get
office it is interesting that well with
that we build a space where people could
connect and be collaborative and that
that's not how we work I mean we like to
isolate ourselves just the two of us you
know what do you remember the time of
night we didn't - we didn't create a
bunch of if we would have created for
our team what we created for ourselves
we would have turned that in that open
area not in a desk but a big living room
where people just lay down on couches
and stuff right remember we went to a
rocket jump was a Freddie's company yeah
remember the first time we went there
you know and I was like where's
Freddie's office and he just had a desk
in the middle of everything with
everybody
yeah and I remember feeling like
questioning questioning us I was like
are we like elitist some prima donnas
separation got this office in the back
you know it's got like a wall of now
what is now dead plants because no one
has been taking care but then I was just
like no I couldn't
III I understand the idea of being in
the middle and being amongst everyone
but I just wouldn't get anything done
and also me and you because it's not one
person it's two people who are
constantly talking through every single
thing that we're doing right sometimes
in a heated fashion just whatever the
process the creative process entails you
don't want to you don't want to watch
that yeah you don't want to try to do
other work when that's happening behind
you that's you you you kind of actually
want to uh
the idea of what it's like for us to
create together is probably better than
the the idea of watching us create
together like let keep the mystery alive
and see the product on the other side
but it gets pretty boring and monotonous
and mathematical in the moment I think
and I don't I don't know you know up
into this conversation I hadn't really
thought about like the different types
of roles here and it's like people are
saying in general some people are gonna
are gonna start working from home well
that's another thing you know so it's
like I haven't really we haven't started
to tackle that question for us so I'm
not I mean but it does change the
convert the people are working at home
but also the fact that there's a change
in the way people are seeing open spaces
that is changing the calculus on how
long we'll be in the space I think you
know because I think there has been a
part of us that's like okay are we gonna
are we gonna need to get another space
that we're gonna need to get a bigger
space I mean we keep growing but things
a lot of things change this year you
know I mean yes there are certain jobs
that can be done from home some people
may actually prefer it there are certain
meetings that could take place on zoom'
do they does everyone really have to be
here for for a all-hands meaning can
some people join by videoconference
you know I think that we're gonna be
answering those questions but I actually
yeah and it it's it's premature so I
guess the last place I wanted just
verbally process is on a podcast but
screw it let's do it
I you know my for my first reaction like
my knee-jerk reaction is to be oh we got
to get back to the way things work is
they were working but it's interesting
that I don't know I have this as a boss
I have this defensive stance it's like
well I ain't gonna you know if if people
start working for moment they were
really gonna get their work done and I
don't know I just found myself thinking
that but I know that well there's other
ways you can answer that and people also
work in certainly some people can say if
people work better and thrive in that
environment
and there's easy ways to still have
accountability to for your deliverables
you know what I'm saying yeah but I also
think that the work from home thing is
complicated like I think about my house
oh yeah but a lot of our employees they
don't have like three two or three kids
running around well not only that I'm of
them do but right it's like most of it
would be a different equation if I was a
single guy or if Jesse and I just had
Barbara and no kids we talked about the
spaces that have meant so much to us
it's like I bet you if I've visited some
of my employees unannounced I'll be like
well Dave this room is that this is a
crew they've created a creative space
for them so you know it's funny I've
even think about mentioning this but you
know we've been talking about how long
are you gonna stay in this house and
like we're doing that work you know
outside and we've had this open
construction pit forever hopefully it'd
be done in a month or two but it's like
how long we gonna stay in this house
we're gonna stay here till Shepherd goes
to college that's another at least seven
years and I think we're kind of leaning
towards that but Jesse and I have been
talking about like okay you know as you
get older and as you live in a space you
just start answering a lot of questions
like well what do we want in a home but
you know I I still don't think we
understood what we really wanted in a
home and I'm very happy with our house
but there's a number of things like just
the idea of finding a place to get you
can't really get away because our house
is very open mm-hm and even in this
little guest house a guest room that is
basically Jesse's office but also our
guest bedroom it's very close to
everything it's like I can everyone who
comes down the stairs every conversation
that's in the kitchen and I told Jesse I
was like I don't know what our next home
will have but you know I'll be 50
probably when we're moving into it and I
just have always had this idea that when
I get to be kind of an old man which I'm
approaching that very quickly I just
want to have one of those offices that's
kind of like dark there's a lot of wood
and it's away from everything and maybe
there's like a long hallway to it I mean
they don't make houses like this anymore
but I just have this vision of just
being able to just have a retreat in my
own home and I probably won't even need
it by that point because my kids won't
be there yeah you're talking about a
panic room I'm just talking about one of
those offices like you see in a in a
movie like a bunch of books with that
you don't read behind you yeah okay
space is important whether it's a
cubicle a little corner of your your
bedroom where you know if you can eat it
doesn't have to be big it doesn't have
to be like rats talking about at the end
of a hallway where you get tired by the
time you get there and so your kids will
never bother you with their bike
problems I can I read between the lines
there okay
I think you get everybody's gotta have a
little nook you know if you got a little
nook that's like this is my little space
I used to go in my room I would go
inside my closet and I had a little
space in my closet where I would just go
in there and sit and it just felt like
this is my space my closet was too dirty
I would go in the Attic I had a little
clean little space in my closet man
there was a box full of foam I don't
know what this foam was for or from but
I would get into that box full of foam
you get inside of the box yeah he was
open top yeah see your little cozy spot
man if you take anything from this
conversation take that take take take
finding your little cozy if I find your
box full of foam no and but I think just
practically especially for those of you
who are in a creative field I do think
that it's important to just ask the
question what is your space how is your
space contributing to what you're trying
to create because I I mean we look back
and we got into a little bit of the
detail but I just think that so much of
what we happen to be creating at the
time was largely dictated by the
decision that we had made about this
and that's why it's gotten it's very
important to us and that's why we were
quick once we realized when not too
quick maybe it took a year or two to
realize once we realized that this space
have become representative of one side
of our jobs we needed to push into the
other side kind of the thing that drives
this whole thing so think about that
creative people and I got a wreck for
you baby wreck baby one two three four I
highly recommend watching 13th on
Netflix just to continue the
conversation of racial equality and the
black lives matter movement and again
keeping that as an active part of our
lives is important to us this is not
just you know this can't just be a flash
in the pan for us personally is what
we've discussed you know we want to be
actively engaged as part of the solution
and not bystanders and you know there's
lots of recommendations floating around
this has been one of them that that that
I watched this documentary
I'll read the summary filmmaker Ava
Duvernay explores the history of racial
inequality in the United States focusing
on the fact that the nation's prisons
are disproportionately filled with
African Americans it was released in
October of 2016 but it I didn't know
that when I watched it and I was like
man they got this out quick and that's
that's just ignorance right then I would
that I would find myself thinking that
like it's so important for this movement
now but like I mean again it's like I
embarrass myself less left and right
with the things that I think because I
just am I just have not been educated
and engaged enough but this documentary
is I mean ninety seven percent on Rotten
Tomatoes very well done in it it gives
you
it gives you an an overview of the the
the dark side the ramifications of the
criminal justice system for for black
Americans yeah one thing how and and how
its set up you know it connects the dots
yeah because I think a really important
aspect of all of this is and this is
something that has that I didn't really
understand for a long time and it was it
was reading you know some black authors
who explain this to me is just
understanding that there yes in 2020
there continue to be a lot of policies
whether it's within our criminal justice
system whether it's within our voting
system political system there are
policies that if you're me you didn't
understand why they were racist I mean
you talk about I mean it talked about
Nixon and his really planting the seeds
for the war on drugs from the Reagan era
and he thought about being the
law-and-order president right I mean
which is exactly what Trump is talking
about now yeah well yeah when I'm when
you when they're industry you're
intentionally using the same language in
order to accomplish what they want right
and there's a way as a white person you
think about these things because I was
that white person who thought about
these things I was like well like we
talked you know we talked about this a
lot two years ago I was like okay voter
ID laws that's not racist that's just
having somebody just requiring somebody
to have an ID to vote how can I be
racist but then when you understand the
history of that approach and who is
being targeted and what is being
prevented and it isn't fraud it's
actually certain groups of people being
prevented from voting and once you
understand the the intention behind it
you're like oh that is why that's a
racist policy so I won't when you talk
about the war on drugs it's like how
could that be bad I mean how could just
say no be bad and when you look at the
policies in place for you know the
punishments associated with crack versus
cocaine versus cocaine yeah which are
the same thing but they're prevalent in
different communities white community
versus the black community well
specifically it was five grams of crack
gave the equivalent prison sentence of
500 grams of cocaine and that was
strictly because cocaine was a white
drug and crack was a black drug and and
again this is all this stuff was
happening we were growing up we were
growing up in a little small town where
we just thought that everybody's got
equal opportunity I mean the civil
rights movement happened years ago
everybody's everything's equal now and
once you start realizing that no no no
no no no no no it's not it's not and
that's the fight that is being fought
right now right and it is a change it is
a fight to change policy is a fight to
change racist policy and if you don't
think that the racist policy exists then
I would my argument paying attention and
so you got you and just watch I'm saying
watch 13th is a greatest place to start
yeah
it lays it all out it gives you
something to not you don't have to agree
with everything to be exposed to educate
your city to be exposed to it and then
reach your own conclusions but I think
it's it's very well made and it was very
eye-opening for me okay well we're back
we're here we're in the studio we're in
the at the round table of dim lighting
and if all goes according to plan we
will be here again next week who knows
what our plans
hashtag ear biscuits love you to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best